واعلنا وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه ان ما
وصفه بناج حلف الناتو المعادل لروسيا
سيؤدي الى تصعيد الصراع في اوكرانيا وقال
ان القوات الروسيه تدمر وبشكل متعمد
الاسلحه التي يرسلها الغرب الى اوكرانيا
سواء في مواقع القتال او اثناء نقلها
ندمر بشكل متعمد الاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه التي ارسلها الغرب الى اوكرانيا
سواء في مواقع القتال او في اثناء نقلها
منذ بدايه العام فقط تم تدميره 59 مدفعيه
من طراز ام 777 و4 عشره منصه اطلاقه مارس
امريكيه الصنع و30 مدفعا ذاتيه الحركه من
بولندا والمانيا وفرنسا وتشيك حلف شمال
الاطلسي يعزز مسارا معاديا لروسيا سيؤدي
الى تصعيد الصراع
ولد حرمه بابا كيف تتابع روسيا هذا
الانضمام الجديد لحلف الناتو من قبل
فنلندا وهي التي قالت ان ذلك سيجبر موسكو
على اتخاذ تدابير مضاده لحمايه امنها
نعم مواقف مختلفه تصدر سواء من الخارجيه
الروسيه من وزاره الدفاعيه روسيا من
الرئاسه من الكريملين تؤكد كلها على هذا
القلق وعلى هذا الحذر التي تنظر به موسكو
تجاه انضمامي
الاطلسي طبعا هذه التصريحات تتضمن تاكيدا
على ان روسيا ستتخذ ما يلزمه من اجراءات
لحمايه امنها القومي في خاصه على الحدود
الفنلنديه الروسيه الممتده على طول اكثر
من 1300 كم وبانها ستعزز حضورها الامنيات
تؤكدها التصريحات على ستعزز حضورها
الامنيه وانتشارها العسكريه في هذه
المنطقه المتاخمه للحدوديه الفنلنديه
والتي تضم احد اهم احده من اهم المدن
الروسيه وهي سام بطرس وكذلك في بحريه
البطيخ توجد قاعده عسكريه توجد يوجد
الاسطول الروسي واحد اهم واحد من اهم
الاساطير البحريه لروسيا في بحريه قرب
الحدودي مع فنلندا اذا هذه الخطوه هي مصدر
قلق بالنسبه لروسيا سواء في تصريحات
الخارجيه في تصريحات وزاره الدفاع وكذلك
في تصريحاته طبعا ما اذا كانت فنلندا او
نوعيه العضويه او سماح في لندن بنشر قوات
عسكريه
متطورا على اراضيها تابع لحلف الناتو ربما
سيحدد ايضا في المرحله المقبله مدى تفاعلي
موسكو ومدى وحجم الاجراءات والمبادرات
التي ستتخدها
للخفض من التهديد الذي قد تم قد تمثله
حضور على في هذه في هذه النقطه قربه
حدودها مع فنلندا طبعا هنالك ايضا حديث
ربما يمكن ربطه بهذا بانضمام فلندا الى حد
في النيتو وهو هل تصريحات المرتبطه بنقل
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا روسيا
تكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا طبعا كان هناك
تصريحات لوزاره الدفاع صباح اليوم بهذا
الشان الى التصريحاته في مجملها هي تعبير
عن هذا القلق عن هذا الرفض تجعل ذلك في
تصريحات وزير الخارجيه
الروسيات وكذلك في تصريحات وزير الدفاع
وكل هذه التصريحات ترفض وتحذر من ما قد
يشكله انضمامه
وكانت علاقته ربما مع موسكو ليست بتلك
العلاقه المطربه مع اوكرانيا مثلا خلال
سنوات او العقود القليله الماضيه كانت
تنتهج نجاه الحياد وربما كما عبر
قد لا يكون انضمام في ذلك الخطر الذي رات
فيه موسكو طلب اوكرانيا الانضمام الى
الحلف خلال السنوات الماضيه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر بابا ولد حرمه مراسلنا